et c'est à vous mademoiselle avec qui je
vais m'adresser moi j'étais devant ma
télé ce soir en pyjama et quand j'ai vu
que vous veniez sur un plateau moi je
suis pas sûr je suis pas du tout
d'accord sauf est de dire faut pas leur
donner la parole
je trouve absolument fabuleux que vous
preniez la parole parce que en général
vous dites n'importe quoi ce qui me
dérange aujourd'hui c'est que sur les
plateaux vous êtes deux fois trois
quatre personnes autour de la table est
d'accord entre vous sur des sujets aussi
graves
et pour aller plus loin que soit enfin
entendu parler de vous c'était le
rassemblement de la famille traoré a
republic vous avez fait les fanfarons à
monter sur le toit est là qu est ce qui
s'est passé derrière parce que ça c'est
plus grave
sans cela on l'envoie regarde et qu'on
va regarder regardez il ya signe de ce
beau coup pas
[Musique]
qu'est ce qui s'est passé c'est que
durant le sprint de 7 personnes sont
venues et ont mis cette affiche et a
écrit à pour les victimes du racisme
avait mis comme à chaque match
et là donc juriste au thalys va répondre
après noël et juste pour répondre à ça
qu'est ce que vous faites après vous
êtes arrêté par la police qui vous
relâcher au bout de 20 minutes est
vraiment il ya des gens qui jouent pas
d'accord c'est pas pardon je finis parce
que j'adore valeurs actuelles mais il
faut que je finisse ma phrase il ya des
gens avec qui je suis pas d'accord mais
objectivement que vous ayez des relais
aujourd'hui de l'autre côté de
l'uniforme
quand il ya deux mois que ça fait un
documentaire j'ai des désaccords en
externe mais quand il y en a pris sa
caméra pour aller filmer des migrants à
calais il n'avait pas besoin de
génération identitaire pour qu'on
retrouve des migrants la gueule dans la
boue en train de vivre dans le froid
mais non pardon de vous dire ça je sais
pas si vous êtes fait voler votre copain
par une arabe en troisième mais en fait
vous n'êtes pas là pour soigner des
maladresses de votre jeunesse et de
faire croire que la génération qui va
venir demain c'est celle de petits
fachos regardez vous faites un seul
fille en vous marrant dans un camion de
police que je compterai que les
associations qui est migrants qui
manifestent mais plein alors une fois
pris en faute il nous avait pris en
photo pour on aimerait c'est un célèbre
thaïs répondait laisser la réponse soit
acquitté pont déjà mature et ses
questions au pérou est courtois soufflet
qui laisserait sympathie s'est un peu
énervé dans la génération identitaire
vous attaquez nos modes d'action alors
que comme a pu le rappeler
geoffroy le jeune ce sont des actions
pacifiques c'est exactement le même mode
d'opération que des ong comme greenpeace
qui font du rhdp n'a tiqué de l'attitude
infini en fait néanmoins ce que
j'aimerais quand même coup levé c'est
que la véritable violence la véritable
violence c'est celle des terroristes
islamistes qui s'infiltrent via les la
voix de l'immigration massive qui
viennent décapiter un samuel pâtit qui
viennent
hébergés dans la cathédrale de nice
matin autour de cette table dans
l'essonne qui a un lien avec des
organisations terroristes en irak une ce
rappel c'est vous parce que c'est à vous
on c'est à vous que le terrorisme non
plus car
lutte héroïque de christian nouvelle
zélande il avait dominé d'orgueil mans
des milliers d'euros à génération
identitaire moi j'ai pas de financer un
gros risque ou si elle cela veut dire
cela fait d'avoir des pages et rend le
migrant pardon j'étais entré dans la
capture à venise et qui a tué trois
personnes
c'est un bain de sang ils étaient entrés
illégalement en france en passant par
lampedusa
nous ce que nous avons fait à la
frontière c'était alerter sur ce danger
nous refusons qu une seule goutte de
sang français ou européens ne recourt à
cause du poteau d'un terroriste il veut
l'egypte qui a tiré sur une mosquée avec
son t-shirt génération de la terre ils
étaient sept occasions étaient français
face à sète mais alors c'est un film x
non mais c'est très grave et c'est le
film s'il va dire jean messier a
franchement aujourd'hui manseng parfois
pour le coup c'est pour ça qu'il faut
pardon sérieux je te le dis
fraternellement mais l'ajustement pardon
il ya des animateurs de télé ce que
vient de dire jean messier a est
gravissime
et alors ce que non mais ça veut dire
quoi j'ai d'ailleurs été français ne l'a
pas dit comme si le gars était et issus
de générations identitaire et qu'il
était français à l'étranger et le gars
qui décapite samuel pâti comme s'il se
revendique d'ailleurs je veux dire un
truc parce que vous avez montré la ban
d'rôle au moment de la manif de que pour
la famille traoré la jeu il faut quand
même rappeler que pendant cette manif et
des slogans antisémites qui ont été
prononcées vrai et lassana